وانتقد جالنت اداء الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المتردد بحسب وصفه وقال ان غياب القرار
السياسي قد يضر بالعمل العسكري ودع جالنت
من وصفهما بالشرك الكبيرين في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الى تعزيز الوحده وتقديم
التنازلات لتحقيق الانتصار في
الحرب اريد ان اتوجه من هنا الى الشريكين
الكبيرين في حكومه الوحده رئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو والوزير بينانس واقول له
هذا وقت الوحده والشراكه هذا وقت الحلول
الوسط بيننا كي نحقق اهداف الحرب من اجلنا
جميعا حكومه الطوارئ هي شرط من اجل
الانتصار في الحرب ودون حكومه الطوارئ
سيذهب كل انجاز وكل ثمن دفعناه سد الرابح
الوحيد من هذا الوضع هو حماس عام
2024 هو سنه حرب وستكون ايضا سنه النصر
سننتصر فيها لاننا محقون ولاننا مصرون
اكثر